agora é só acaba quando essa pele linda
quanto dinheiro vai embora quando à
rasca afirma o pai do dono nem eu nem
ele nem eu
e aí é que ronaldo bom você está também
hoje ele está bem é um amigo meu que
terminou o namoro dele e eu observo os
amigos eu vim prestar atenção numa coisa
quando a pessoa termina o namoro a
pessoa termina o namoro ela tem que dar
aquela animação imbecil que da pessoa a
pessoa termina o namoro ela quer mostrar
para todo mundo que ela está muito bem e
vai ficar tudo bem também deixa o que
acaba de terminar o namoro com ela a
etapa que minha família está aqui eu
estava na festa que estava namorando
essa última agora de cinco anos de
namoro o besteirol a pensar insiste em
querer mostrar pra você que ela também
já foi a seguinte para a festa embora a
festa vai ter vai querer janeth moreno
forró cheiro a morte vai ser massa de
maio embora mas cheguei a ficar em casa
e descansar um pouco vai ver vou pegar
essa sucata tudim tudinho convive comigo
ela vai ganhar muito feliz que tudo
termine show ea pessoa até meu namoro
tudo que era para fazer depois que ela
terminou o namoro ela faz o contrário em
vez de ela sair encontrar com os amigos
tentasse animal que ela faz é assim tudo
foi bem de casa não tem no mundo quem
tira essa pessoa de dentro do quarto já
fazendo 4 e escutar uma música legal a
música pra ser bacana o que ela faz
a chuva acabou e vai ficar mais três
fica pior o que ela faz se ela tentar
esquecer a pessoa não ela fica então no
hati zap ficar olhando a última hora que
a pessoa visualizou que por exemplo por
nove horas da noite ea pessoa que até
não tiver visualizado atizhar 3h da
tarde que ela pensa o meu deus ela já
está contra o cara meu deus ta phut bem
desde três horas da tarde até agora eu
não acho que a pessoa que até não tiver
um lay naquele momento ela não fica
feliz porque ela pensa em matar um líder
agora não está falando comigo no domingo
está conversando com alguns bêbado livre
o tempo que eu vou fazer da minha vida
você pensa que a pessoa que você
terminou com outra pessoa naquele
momento em que a pessoa que você
terminou tal olhando por celular e na
hora que você visualizou viu que você
está online o que é que a pessoa que
você tem não está pensando o meu tenta
não acredito que ele também está
conversando conta pessoal aí este
vagabundo eu sabia que quando eu morava
no banheiro não é a galera conversando
qualquer vagabundo já tá pegando da
menina o meu deus tá pensando que a
minha pega num novo ea minha está
pensando que o cara tá pegando nove
ninguém tá pegando ninguém e o pior é
que quando a pessoa termina o namoro às
vezes ela quer esquecer ela terminou um
namoro mas as pessoas que estão ao redor
dela faz a questão de lembrar
principalmente as tia ea mãe aí meu
filho como é que a escola ambiente é
também informar agora um emprego como
ela no emprego também tirar essa de
aumentar o salário tudo em meio a
namorada como está com a namorada pois é
não tomar nem com ela nem com o meu
tempo na qualificação tamanho que ela
não gostava tanto dela o meu deus sabe
o nome então ainda não é meu filho com
aquela será quem é que vai namorar com
ela agora depois de você tomar que seja
um rapaz tão bom quanto você e eu possuo
com 70 namorada com aquela menina nunca
mais deixaria escapar das minhas boas na
minha vida o meu deus do céu a [ __ ]
godoy pelo menos já deve estar se
divertindo e ficando com outra pessoa
nova o rapaz assim mar bonilha também
merece é uma pessoa linda maravilhosa e
rica também que posso concordar com ela
a vida é assim quem não dá valor e às
vezes perde a vez perde a pessoa que não
dá valor uma pessoa tão bonita nunca
tinha visto alguém tão lindo com as
coxas uma muda com uma tela lhe um peito
do menino davi meu deus meu filho mas a
vida é assim mesmo vai dar tudo certo
não fique triste não porque a vida a
vida meu filho ela ensina as pessoas do
lado mais difícil ela não tá aqui pra
falar como é que agora uma coisa que
sempre acontece quando a pessoa termina
namoro terminou namoro vai para a
primeira festa que tem tomar o primeiro
copo de cachaça que vem na frente pega o
primeiro celular que topa pela frente e
vai levar a pessoa que estava e ele me
deu eu tô pegando me agarrava tomé tem
no banco quer mostrar pra pessoa que
está bem e vai passar vergonha isso no
começo da festa no meio da festa de um
xingamento olha o agarrou com tudo novo
mundo e tudo que prometeu negócio vai
sair vamos pegar esse seus amigos cana
da [ __ ] isso no meio da festa vem no
final da festa o que a declaração todos
terão medo vou tomar melhor eu te ama
sempre um dia de óleo se encontra no
medo do amp steel qualquer aí pra
caramba ter filhos uau bem o adversário
e levamos o filho vai estudar york o
esporte é um apostado unido vai tomar
no final o carro é um filho meu filho
vou ter que você olha eu prometo nunca
mais vou te amar tem gente célula e
bebida não combinam principalmente para
quem tem twitter já diz aquela frase
publicitária se beber não tweet que a
pessoa quando ela bebe ela comece passar
sim gente está doidona de reais então
faz se não tá agora a pior coisa quando
você termina um namoro é que aparece
logo o choro não a bebida não música
deprimente não as falcioni quando você
termina um namoro falciani aparelho faz
um semana e os seus amigos é esse que
você diz que são seus amigos que atuam
de hoje faz um mês
ou melhor desde o começo do namoro a
pessoa fala sentar aqui o meu namorado
aí passei a minha namorada nova york a
cara bonita bem legal bacana você sai e
chuto viu a namorada do cara meu irmão
tudo e todos e eu pergunto tom e macho
falei isso não mata mulher de amigo meu
pra mim é um homem vilma agora terminou
namoro família panicat já estão de olho
e pode montar um negócio aí podia e
terminei um namoro boé oi oi que tomar
cuidado com os seus amigos na de recife
e galé de caruaru dia 8 e 9 está fazendo
show aí dia 8 em recife dia 9 em caruaru
como comprar os ingressos primeiro
ninguém aqui na descrição do vídeo muito
obrigada a assistir se vir até aqui se
você gostou
deixa eu gostei aqui no vídeo é muito
importante que você volte lá no meu
facebook onde você vê essa postagem
clique em curtir e marca seus amigos que
já terminaram o namoro viu essa postagem
no twitter
volta lá e da rtp que você me ajuda
demais a gratuitas ainda está lançado no
facebook se escreve aqui no canal panda
bear de um vídeo e valeu é nóis falou em
berlim e em verdade recife dia 8 caruaru
dia 9 vamos embora